What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
We have hit 300k subscribers
So it's time for me and Otto
To play a one set match!
This should be an interesting one.
Do we have a yellow card here?
I would give him a yellow card.
That will be a yellow card!
Good serve!
Don't give me there.
I don't have enough room here!
I had him! I had him under control!
My favorite shot...
Well played!
Game and match to Miikka!
So I lost this one, but I'm sure I will beat you in a best of 7 match.
I think that once we reach 500K subscribers
It's time for the full match!
And to make things a bit more interesting:
If Otto loses, I will cut his beard.
And If I lose, he will get to shave my head.
Yeah, I won't lose this one!